reino unido busca una solución
diplomática con el ánimo de disuadir una
posible agresión contra ucrania el
gobierno británico presentará esta
semana una nueva legislación para
ampliar el alcance de las sanciones que
puede aplicar a rusia actualmente sólo
se puede sancionar a las empresas
directamente implicadas en la
desestabilización de ucrania en un
anuncio este domingo la ministra de
asuntos exteriores británica liz trust
dijo que en la nueva ley se podrán
incluir sanciones para instituciones
financieras y energéticas rusas cercanas
al kremlin y aunque ter se ha dicho que
es muy poco probable que reinó unido-
envía soldados británicos a luchar junto
a las tropas ucranianas si especificó el
apoyo militar que está proporcionando en
la zona
estamos ofreciendo el despliegue de
tropas adicionales en estonia más apoyo
aéreo a través del mar negro y
suministrando armas defensivas a ucrania
para asegurarnos de que están en la
mejor posición posible en caso de que
vladimir putin intente realizar una
incursión
intente statement ocasión la otan
aseguró que tampoco planea desplegar
tropas de combate en ucrania
combatir no tenemos planes de desplegar
tropas de combate de la otan en ucrania
los aliados de la otan tienen
entrenadores allí pero nuevamente
ucraniano es un aliado de la otan el
ministro de relaciones exteriores de
rusia reiteró que el verdadero plan de
la otan es atraer a ucrania a la alianza
y le pidió a la organización que
explique cómo van a cumplir su
compromiso en materia de seguridad si no
tienen intención de hacerlo deben
explicar por qué esta será una cuestión
clave para determinar nuestras futuras
propuestas con la presión de más de
100.000 soldados rusos en la frontera la
atención en ucrania sigue aumentando a
la espera de lo peor
[Aplausos]